كانت هذه هي اللحظة في اليوم الأول من
هذه الحرب ،
بدأت خطة روسيا لضربة صاعقة على
القطار تتفكك من
الداخل هنا ، وشاهدنا هذه
القوات الروسية المحمولة جواً خفيفة التسليح
تقاتل من أجل الحفاظ على حياتها
في ضواحي كييف ،
والآن قال وزير الدفاع الأوكراني لـ
CNN  تم انتشال أوامر عسكرية مكتوبة
من جثة ضابط روسي
قُتل هنا مما يؤكد أن
قادته الروس
توقعوا تحقيق نصر سريع وسهل
كان عليه أن يكون في الحي الحكومي بعد
12 ساعة من الغزو منذ
بدء مركز الغزو
في الكيوي الذي كان عليه السيطرة عليه.
مبنى الحكومة ، مكتب رئيس
البرلمان
، وبعد 72
ساعة من التأكد
من إخلاء الرئيس على سبيل المثال في
وقت لاحق ، يبدو الأمر ساذجًا بشكل مذهل ،
أليس كذلك ، وبصراحة ، كان
شركاؤنا في عواصم العالم المختلفة
ساذجين أيضًا ، كما
أخبرونا أيضًا  أن الغزوات وشيكة
وسوف تسقط
لديك 72 ساعة فقط
ولكن لما يقرب من أربعة أشهر  الآن
، تمسك أوكرانيا بهزيمة
القوات الروسية بالقرب من العاصمة
بمساعدة أسلحة خارقة للدروع من
الولايات المتحدة
وآخرين ، وقد خصصت إدارة بايدن بالفعل
40 مليار دولار لهذه
المعركة
، ويصر وزير الدفاع الأوكراني على
أن واشنطن وحلفاءها قد
أكدوا.  له أن الدعم
سيستمر لن يتوقف شركاؤنا أبدًا
، قيل
لي إنني تحدثت مع
صديقي الضائع في
لويد أوستن وزير دفاع
الولايات المتحدة وزير الدفاع في
المملكة المتحدة
بن والاس وزملائنا الآخرين
قالوا لي أن أليكس لا يفعل  قلق من أننا لن
نتوقف ، هل تعتقد حقًا
أن هذا التزام حقيقي من قبل
الولايات المتحدة لمواصلة إعادة أوكرانيا عسكريًا
إلى المستقبل بغض النظر
عما سمعته بالأمس وشعرت أنه
بصراحة تامة
وأن الأوكرانيين صادقون أيضًا بشأن
ما هم  أسلحة جديدة ستكون
لأسلحة مثل أحدث
بنادق مدفعية ثلاثية الأبعاد من طراز M من الولايات المتحدة
والتي تم عرضها في سوب.  هيرن أوكرانيا في
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر
أو قاذفات الصواريخ المتعددة
التي ستدخل الخدمة هنا قريبًا ،
قال وزير الدفاع إنهم سيساعدون
أوكرانيا على استعادة الأراضي المحتلة ،
وسنقوم بتحرير كل أراضينا
، كل ذلك ،
ماذا عن شبه
جزيرة القرم ، إنها  الأرض الأوكرانية
بالنسبة لي أمر مفهوم تمامًا ، لذا
فأنت تقول إن القرم هي هدف عسكري
للقوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
باستخدام هذا السلاح.
المرحلة الأولى ،
الاستقرار
، سأنتهي من المرحلة الثانية ، وهي أن
أطردهم حتى الوضع الحدودي في 24
فبراير
والمرحلة الثالثة سنناقشها مع
شركائنا حول كيفية تحرير
أراضينا ، بما في ذلك شبه جزيرة القرم ،
ولن يسير أي من هذا بشكل جيد في
موسكو وحتى مع الأسلحة الغربية المتقدمة
لتحل محل هذه الأسلحة السوفيتية القديمة تبدو أوكرانيا مستعدة
لخوض معركة طويلة